just to give you a brief introduction
you know who Chelsea is if you don't
know her but you know there's so much
more it can be said and I will tell you
in this like one short paragraph she's
the assistant director of computer
science and electrical engineering at
Stanford University and her lab is
called Iris so you will see a little bit
of logo of an iris and she studies
intelligence through robotic interaction
at scale and it's very actually
fascinating field of research he will be
telling you more about today uh so thank
you again for joining she also spends
time at Google as part of the Google
brain team and yeah it's my big pleasure
that she's able to join join us uh she's
also going to teach two classes actually
just in couple of weeks and you can find
more information on the platform one of
them is graduate class cs224r deep
learning deeper enforcement learning
which starts on April 2nd and the other
one is a professional class accessory
survey deep multitask and meta learning
and it starts only I think next Monday
so it's very very soon uh so yeah she's
a wonderful instructor wonderful person
to have like here so thank you so much
once again for joining really happy to
be here and excited about to share some
of our research on uh deep learning for
Robotics and specifically talk about
where the frontier is I'm also seeing
some questions in the Q a about there
being a recording and yes this will be
recorded and the recording will be
posted online
great so
um to get started uh I think a great
place to start is to think about what
can robots do today and we've seen
examples of robots being able to
complete fairly complex manipulation
tasks like being able to use a spatula
to lift an object into a bowl
or really impressive videos from Boston
Dynamics that allow robots to do really
impressive Maneuvers
um such as kind of Parkour like
Maneuvers in uh in environments like
this
and the catch with um with these kinds
of impressive behaviors is that uh first
in terms of the Boston Dynamics Behavior
Uh it's really undoubtedly impressive
but the behavior was manually tuned for
this one particular environment
and the manipulation task of using the
spatula to lift an object was trained
using 15 minutes of data in that
environment
and as a result uh these behaviors are
specialized to the environments that
they were trained in and the
environments that the behavior was tuned
for
and this means that they're learning
very narrow behaviors that robots are
able to perform complex Maneuvers in
narrow and controlled environments and
if you moved one of these different
platforms a little bit or if you gave
the robot a different spatula the
behavior would ultimately fail
and so what I'm really interested in is
how we might allow robots to actually go
out into the real world in real
environments like homes offices and so
forth and actually allow them to
generalize to perform intelligent
behavior in those settings
now the tricky part is that we often
train robots
um on a fairly narrow distribution such
as in a lab environment and our goal is
to be able to actually deploy these
robots into the real world
and from the standpoint of machine
learning this means that actually
generalizing to this wider distribution
is pretty challenging because it was
trained on a fairly narrow distribution
but the small number of objects and a
small number of environments
and so
I think that there's two possible
solutions and I think that both of these
Solutions are really important
um the first is to train on a larger and
broader data set try to think if we can
scale the data that we're training
robots on so that they can generalize
um fairly broadly and arguably this
training neural networks on larger data
sets is one of the only recipes that's
convincingly enabled in the wild
generalization in other domains like
speech recognition machine translation
and image classification
uh and I think that this this sort of
thing will be really important and
necessary to get robots to generalize
but I think that actually doing this uh
won't quite be sufficient because I
think that robots will inevitably
encounter scenarios that are a little
bit different than the scenarios that
they are trained on simply because the
world is is vast and has lots of
different
um scenarios and lots of different
environments and objects and so forth
and so the second ingredient that I
think is really important is to think
about how robots might also be able to
generalize beyond the data that they
were trained on
and I don't think we can hope to
anticipate every possible scenario so
what we're going to look at is thinking
about whether we can allow the robots to
adapt at test time also and if they're
able to take in a tiny amount of
experience at test time and adapt and
learn from that experience then they
might be able to actually handle novel
situations
so
um these two things training on broader
data sets and generalizing beyond the
training distribution are the two main
things that I'll talk about uh in this
webinar
and um and of course this will only
really be scratching the surface of this
broader topic of uh of deep learning for
robotics but should give you a pretty
good sense for where the field is at
today
great so um first let's think about
whether we can train uh robots across
many different tasks
and the specific goal that we're going
to focus on is to allow a robot to
generalize to a new task that wasn't
specifically trained to do and we're
hoping to be able to do this by actually
broadening the training data
distribution
we're mentioning that there are some
previous uh kind of research efforts
that have tried to aim to allow robots
to generalize to new tasks by for
example enabling robots to generalize to
new objects
um but this was all test trained and
tested within the single skill of
placing
or being able to generalize to new
instructions like new language
instructions but the new instructions
will describe behaviors seen in the data
what we'd like to do is we'd like to
take this a little bit further and be
looking at allowing robots to generalize
uh two different combinations of objects
across a wide range of skills
so
um in terms of evaluating whether a
robot can do a new task
I will consider an example so say the
robot is in this scene and we want to be
able to tell the robot to place the
grapes in the ceramic Bowl
um the robot in this case the data it
will have seen will be showing it how to
place other objects into the ceramic
bowl and how to do other things with the
grapes but it won't have ever seen a
behavior that picks up grapes and puts
it into the ceramic Bowl all in one
trajectory
um and to make things a little bit
harder than that we're actually only
going to show it data from two different
object sets and it won't have ever seen
any data of the grapes and this ceramic
Bowl in the same scene
great so then we're going to trade it on
100 uh total sets of tasks where a task
corresponds to
um kind of a specific behavior or
trajectory and these tasks are going to
cover nine different underlying skills
including things like grasping placing
pushing wiping and so forth
and an example of these kinds of
behaviors is shown in this video where
you can see examples such as placing the
banana in the tray dragging the ceramic
Bowl in a circle and so forth
great
um so this is an example of the behavior
that we're showing the robot and this
this data was collected by using a VR
controller to move the gripper of the
robot in a in a particular in a
particular way and this is an example of
12 different tasks but we're going to
show a data of around 100 different
tasks
and then once we collect this data
showing 100 different tasks we're then
going to train a neural network policy
that will take as input an RGB image and
output a desired Target position and
orientation of the gripper and so um
this policy will outputting seven
numbers three numbers for the position
three for the orientation as well as one
number that corresponds to the opening
and closing of the grouper and this
policy will operate at 10 Hertz such
that it takes in a new image
um 10 times every second and predicts a
new action
we chose this representation because
it's maximally General this sort of
policy in principle could do lots of
different tasks depending on the data
that you traded on and importantly this
policy is also going to be conditioned
on a description of the task and we're
specifically going to use language
descriptions and we'll use a fixed
pre-trained language model to get
embeddings of these instructions and
then pass those embeddings into the
policy
great um so once we've trained this
policy on our diverse data set
in order for the robot to generalize to
a new task the robot needs to be able to
First correctly interpret the language
command second visually identify
relevant objects and distractors
and lastly translate is interpretation
of the instruction and what it sees into
the robot's action space
and doing this all for a novel task is
uh is quite challenging and
um as we'll see um we are actually able
to get some degree of generalization so
for example uh if we go back to the
scenario that we looked at before where
the goal was to place the grape in the
ceramic Bowl we gave it exactly that
language instruction and this is again a
task a trajectory that it never saw in
the data and the robot is able to
successfully complete the task
um similarly and the thing that's really
great is that the
um the robot isn't able to just uh
just kind of perform
one task but it's actually able to
perform a number of different uh tasks
that it didn't see in uh in the training
set such as placing the banana on the
white sponge placing a bottle in the
tray and pushing a purple Bowl across
the table
great so now let's look at some of the
the actually quantitative experiments
that actually evaluate the success of
the policy
and in particular we pre-selected a set
of 28 tasks that are held out from uh
from all of the training data
and then we evaluated performance and I
emphasized pre-selected in the sense
that we didn't kind of just pick the
tasks that that the robot worked on we
pre-selected
um a number of tasks that are all held
out
um all these tasks are shown uh in this
big table right here
and uh we see that first uh the robot
has a non-zero success rate for 20 out
of 28 of the held out tasks
um the average success rate is around 32
over all of the 28 tasks and so overall
this suggests first that there is really
substantial signs of the robot being
able to do tasks that it never saw any
training data for which is really
exciting
um but second there's also considerable
room for improvement in actually
boosting this number
um from 32 upward
and then you can ask where is the room
for improvement in terms of uh the
robot's ability to do these tasks
and so to understand where the room for
improvement is we evaluated the robot's
performance with um on the training
tasks uh with either a just like a one
hot ID for the task as well as a
language instruction for the task and
then we also evaluated of course this
kind of 32 number which is held out
tasks with language conditioning
and first we see that if we actually
evaluate the robot on training tasks on
tasks that it was trained to do the
performance is actually only 40 there's
only an eight percent Gap in being able
to actually generalize to a new task
um and the Really larger Gap is actually
bringing up this 42 number up to 100 and
this means that really the bottleneck is
just the robot's ability to complete the
tasks in the first place
and we can actually look at
um kind of example failure cases of
um
example failure cases of what the uh
kind of robot does for tasks that it has
a zero percent success rate for
and um I'm not sure if these videos are
playing but the
um kind of what these videos show is
that even though this policy has a zero
percent success rate uh the robot is
actually really close to completing the
task so for the place banana in the
ceramic cup it actually knows to pick up
the banana and move it towards the cup
but doesn't quite complete the last
stage of the task
and for the second task of wiping the
tray with a sponge it also figures out
that it should pick up the sponge and
tries to kind of move towards the tray
but it isn't able to complete the very
last stage of the task
and so this is just that first the zero
percent um success metric is quite
strict uh and it also suggests that we
just um that kind of just the ability to
kind of control the robot arm is the
major bottleneck in terms of completing
these tasks
great
um so that was kind of a proof of
concept that we can actually allow
robots to generalize to new tasks which
is uh to start to generalize a new task
which is pretty exciting
um now there's a question of what if we
scale up even more so we are previously
looking at around 100 tasks
the next step is we tried actually
scaling this to more than 700 tasks uh
using 130 000 trajectories or
demonstrations of those tasks
we found that if we took the model from
kind of the previous work that I
mentioned and just tried to make it
larger that didn't actually necessarily
improve performance it seems like this
larger this kind of model architecture
isn't able to actually absorb all of the
information in this larger data set
and so what we did is we once we scaled
up this data set we tried to actually
see if we could design an architecture
that is better at capturing
um better at capturing all of the kind
of detailed information in this larger
data set
and so specifically we designed what
we're referring to as a robotics
Transformer
um similar to four this could be taking
an input input images and an instruction
and outputting an action
but there's a number of important
components that allow this architecture
to be better at absorbing lots of data
the first is that we're going to
tokenize the inputs and the outputs into
discrete tokens
we're going to use a Transformer uh to
as part of this architecture and
Transformers have been widely used in
natural language processing and we find
that they're actually a very effective
architecture here as well for being able
to leverage large amounts of data and
we'll
um because our actions are now
discretized with tokens we'll use a kind
of a cross-entropy style objective
uh and then for reading his input the
images will use a kind of a
convolutional neural network
um called an efficient net as well as a
film architecture at a condition on the
instruction
um this backbone of the network will be
pre-trained uh and then the output of
these um these image embeddings will be
tokenized uh with uh a token learner I
don't want to get into too much of the
details here
um
but the biggest part here is that we're
able to actually train this on um on a
really large data set on a 130 000
episodes this data set was collected
across 13 robots over 17 months covering
more than 700 tasks
and what we found is when we actually
evaluated this model uh on uh both scene
tasks as well as tasks that were unseen
distractors that were new and different
background scenes uh this model
architecture is shown in blue was able
to kind of substantially outperform
previous model architectures including
the architecture that we used in the
previous work as well as the gato style
architecture which is a an architecture
developed by deepmind
um great so kind of the takeaway here is
that uh if we scale up robotics data and
train these big policies on these broad
data sets that allows robots to start to
generalize in lots of different ways
including to new tasks uh new distractor
objects in the scene and new backgrounds
in the scene
um we've also released the data from the
first work and there's a link available
right here
great
um and then the other thing that I'd
like to briefly touch on on this kind of
data set front is
um
is kind of this bigger level picture
which is that typically in robot
learning research
um the way that most research progresses
is that first we will collect a data set
for a project
then kind of complete that project with
that data set and then kind of don't use
that data again for the next project for
the next project we'll kind of collect a
new data set for that product
and as you might imagine uh this is
really inefficient and if you contrast
this to what typical machine learning
research does outside of Robotics
typically one data set is collected once
um like imagenet or Wiki text and it's
reused many many times by many different
research projects
uh or even better instead of reusing the
data set we might reuse a model that was
pre-trained on that data set and
fine-tune that model or use embeddings
from that model
and so I think it's really important for
the kind of robot learning research as a
whole to kind of move towards the second
Paradigm and try to move towards a
scenario where we're sharing data and
pre-trained models across institutions
and of course across projects as well
um if so I think if we were able to
share data in pre-trained models in
robotics then I think we could probably
make a lot more progress on the really
challenging research problems that come
up here uh and for example if if you
imagine like what machine learning
research
um if machine learning research did what
robot learning research does and they
kind of recollected
um image debt for every single project
uh that would probably be quite
expensive and probably computer vision
wouldn't be where it is today
great
um so then I'll also briefly comment on
like what's actually stopping us from
sharing data across institutions right
now
um I think we have a little bit of a a
challenge in that
um kind of I'll make an analogy which is
that I think that right now what the
robot data landscape looks like is
all these different islands in this
giant ocean where
we have these different robot data sets
that have been collected
um and each of them is kind of an island
that covers the whole Space of possible
kind of robot configurations
environments objects and so forth
and because these data sets are not
super diverse and because the whole
possible space of Robotics hardware and
environments and so forth is so broad
this means that when another research
project is kind of going to um kind of
try out a task and try out studying a
particular problem
um that research project usually ends up
somewhere over here or over here
and this means that the data sets that
have been collected before aren't useful
for actually advancing that new robotics
experiment or that new kind of task or
problem or environment
and so one of the efforts that we're
trying to do right now is to try to see
um first if we can collect data from
many many distinct environments
um not just from one building
and also trying to see if we can have a
kind of more centralized Community
Driven data collection effort that may
allow us to unify some of the design
choices so that first we can have a
larger Island and second we can kind of
bring more people towards a single
Island by actually having everyone agree
upon certain design choices
and so
um our goal is to collect data from lots
of different real household environments
our initial goal was around 50 different
households but we actually think that we
might be able to significantly expand
that with the kind of interest that
we've seen so far
um and we've been kind of developing a
kind of integrating people from lots of
different universities to try to
contribute to this effort and of course
if you're interested in contributing
feel free to reach out
cool so
um the first part of this talk I talked
about trying to train robots on broader
data sets and we saw that we can get
signs of zero shot generalization to new
tasks and environments but we should
also probably try to share data across
institutions and reuse data more
frequently such that we could allow
robots to actually generalize further
and generalize to the extent that we see
uh things outside of
robotics generalizing well
great so now I'd like to also briefly
talk about how robots might generalize
beyond the training distribution
and we'll first look at this in the
context of a simple grasping problem
where the training environment and the
grasping policy was initially kind of
trained in this sort of environment it's
kind of a bin its goal is to pick
objects from this bin
and
um we're going to then try to test their
policy in a number of different
environments and we're actually
specifically on going to pick
environments that we found that the
policy worked poorly in this includes
with harsh lighting conditions with
transparent objects that it didn't see
during training with the checkerboard
background as well as a physical change
where we actually moved the gripper of
the robot by 10 centimeters
and the policy in the training
environment was fairly successful it had
an 86 success rate
and when we actually tried to put it
under these new conditions the success
rate dropped significantly to 32 49 50
and 43 percent
and
um one of the things I mentioned before
is that it's really impossible to
anticipate and prepare for any possible
scenario that the robot might find
itself in and so what we're going to do
is we're going to try to see if the
robot can adapt to a small amount of
data that was collected in this new
environment
and so
specifically what this will look like is
we have our original data set collected
in the original environment we're going
to use a reinforcement learning
algorithm called qtop to train a q
function and a policy for grasping in
this environment this policy again gets
86 success rate
and then we're going to allow the robot
to collect a very small amount of data
only 800 attempts which can be collected
in around a single afternoon
in this new environment
um in this case uh this is uh the
display stripper
and then we're going to take our Q
function and simply fine tune it on this
target data using a mixture of the base
data and the new data
and uh then with this very simple fine
tuning procedure which is a kind of very
common in in the rest of machine
learning we see that the policy can get
around a 98 success rate even though
this uh kind of environment is
completely different from what it saw
during training
um and uh we kind of did a pretty fairly
thorough quantitative evaluation there
looking at a variety of kind of physical
changes and and visual changes I don't
want to get into all the numbers here
but a few highlights is that first we
can see a fairly strong Improvement in
success rate even after only 25 new
attempts in the new environment
and um
and uh here's actually kind of a video
of the policy
um of the policy in uh one of these new
environments and so
um in this case with kind of an
afternoon afternoon's worth of data it's
able to adapt to this new scenario and
um and successfully handle uh this um
the um the kind of the physical change
that we imposed on the robot
cool so this was all specifically in the
context of grasping um and we saw that
the robot can autonomously collect some
data to adapt to a new setting
now what about kind of in general can we
do this for any sort of Robotics task
ideally
um what we could do is we could allow
the robot to kind of autonomously
collect data uh and adapt with that
collected data but there's a little bit
of a challenge here
and the challenge is that if we collect
a trajectory with reinforcement learning
the robot attempts the task we collect
one trajectory and then we collect
another trajectory and so on and so
forth
typically in reinforcement learning with
the sort of trial and error process we
assume that the robot can attempt the
task multiple times
but one um kind of subtle point is that
it's actually unclear if we want the
robot to autonomously adapt on its own
how it will actually get to the last
state of a trajectory back to the first
date of its next attempt to retry the
task
and in a lot of simulation environments
you can just kind of reset the
environment
um and allow it to attempt it again
but in the real world if we want robots
to adapt on the fly in their new kind of
deployed setting this sort of reset uh
isn't possible it might require a human
to do something
um and it prevents the robot from kind
of autonomously adapting with a small
amount of data
and so
um oftentimes what this looks like is
for example if a robot is trying to hit
a puck into a goal uh this robot
actually isn't physically capable of of
moving the the puck back and oftentimes
a human will reset the puck between each
trial
um or if the robot's trying to learn how
to open a door uh a person will kind of
then close the door uh before every
trial
what ideally we'd like to be able to do
is to allow robots to adapt without
these kinds of resets
now you might ask well maybe we can just
run reinforcement learning algorithms
without resets
um just kind of run the same exact
algorithms that we use when they do get
these kinds of resets and maybe those
are still work
um and so we we tried doing that so we
took a very simple environment where the
goal is uh kind of in simulation to have
this fish move to a certain goal
and it turns out that
um if you give it a reset every Thousand
Steps it learns a performance policy at
the task
but if you give it a reset only every
2000 steps it isn't able to get as high
of performance over the course of
learning
and if you give it a reset even less
frequently the robot heartily is able to
learn a policy for the task at all
and so perhaps surprisingly algorithms
for reinforcement learning aren't well
designed for this scenario where the
robot is operating completely
autonomously on its own and this means
that if we want to use these algorithms
to allow robots to adapt during
deployment at test time in the real
world they aren't going to be well
suited for that
uh and so this motivated us to introduce
this problem of single life
reinforcement learning
um and in contrast to episodic
reinforcement learning where you can try
things again and again or reset free
reinforcement learning where you can
kind of try to both learn how to do the
task and undo the task
what we're going to look at is a
scenario where we have some previous
experience and so the robot has possibly
used these previous experiences to learn
a good policy
then the agent is faced with a new
environment at test time and its goal is
to basically complete the task fully
autonomously within a single episode
without any human resets
in that new environment at test time
um and so kind of more succinctly given
previous data in a training environment
the robot or the agent has one life to
autonomously complete the task in a
novel scenario
um
we'll be starting to look at this in a
very simple simulated environment
um we'll I'll show some examples in this
half cheetah environment where for
example in during training it just needs
to run forward and at test time it sees
a scenario that's completely different
from anything it saw during training
specifically there'll be an obstacle
that makes it harder to make forward
progress
great
um
and so then our goal will actually be to
allow the robot to actually figure out
how to adapt at test time
um within a single episode
cool so um how do we go about
approaching this problem so uh first
what we did is we actually tried to run
um run the robot in this environment and
its goal is to get to the green box
and it was trained in an environment
without any obstacles at all
and what we're doing here is we're
running the robot in a simulated
environment and we're fine-tuning it
with reinforcement learning to try to
have it update its policy and ultimately
uh get to the the green block
and ideally kind of what we see here is
it actually gets a little stuck it gets
knocked upside down and it struggles to
make forward progress and kind of get
back up first figure out how to get back
up and then figure out how to get over
the obstacle to get to the goal
and so really the core challenge of this
sort of single life reinforcement
learning problem is to handle this sort
of novelty and recover from these out of
distribution states such as being
knocked upside down without any sort of
human intervention
I'm in standard uh kind of reinforcement
learning algorithms that run fine-tuning
in this environment will kind of won't
encourage the agent to recover from out
of distribution States
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
first um encourage the agent to move
towards the distribution of Prior data
because this should help it figure out
that when it's knocked back over it
should try to get back up because that's
a state that it saw in its previous data
um but we don't want to exactly do that
uh these kinds of previous methods
usually assume expert demonstrations and
they aim to match the entire
distribution of Prior data
and instead what we're going to do is
we're going to have it
um try to match the prior data but do so
in a way that's weighted by the
estimated value of those States
um and the Q function uh or the Q value
function will estimate the desirability
of the state we can pre-train a q value
our Q function on the previous data and
then kind of try to match the prior data
weighted by the exponentiated uh Q value
of those experiences
and this will drive it towards kind of
states that had good outcomes in the
previous data and we actually tried to
run this on the same example that I
mentioned before
uh and the um what we see here is that
the robot is um again trying to get over
the hurdles uh and ideally what it would
do is it would kind of
um figure out how to get to the goal on
its own and we see exactly that so it
does actually flip over on his back at
one point
um but most importantly it actually is
able to figure out how to get back up on
its feet and also figure out how to get
over the hurdles and ultimately reach
the goal
um we also quantitatively evaluated this
on um not just the scenario that I
showed you but also a few other
scenarios
um and we found that in comparison to
um fine-tuning with reinforcement
learning this approach shown in yellow
was more successful at completing the
task at test time and was able to do so
in a smaller number of steps compared to
fine-tuning with reinforcement learning
um there's also a lot of room for
improvement so I think that this sort of
problem setting that we're introducing
for the first time
um can actually can be studied much
further and actually allow hopefully in
the long run robots to be able to adapt
to new environments and and handle novel
States
great um so to summarize the second part
uh I think it's important to allow
robots to generalize two new scenarios
that they weren't didn't see during
training by actually having them try to
problem solve and learn at test time and
we saw some initial evidence that we
might be able to do that by encouraging
the robot to move towards previous
um data that it saw in the past
um but of course there's also lots of I
think important research to be done
before actually
um actually just being like a viable
solution in the long term and we're
actively working on trying to deploy
this onto real robots so that um
so that robots can try to adapt it test
time rather than deploying a static
policy
um so yeah overall I talked about how we
might allow robots to generalize broadly
by training on a broader data set and
also allowing robots to adapt beyond the
training distribution
the last thing I'd like to touch on
Beyond um generalization
is that I also think it's important to
allow robots to perform very complex and
dexterous tasks so we really focused a
lot on generalization in this talk
but
um ideally robots wouldn't just be doing
very simple tasks like uh the very
simple Locomotion problem that I showed
you grasping and um and kind of pick and
place tasks ideally we could also allow
robots to do more complex tasks like
folding laundry or
um or tasks that uh require like fairly
delicate Maneuvers like peeling a
hard-boiled egg for example
and I think to do this uh to do this
well we need actually a data collection
setup that allows robots to do
um kind of Fairly complex tasks and
ideally set up as low cost and has an
easy to use tele operation system
and so this is something that we've
actually been developing it's still
um still in some way of the early stages
but we developed a low-cost uh system
that allows the robot to
complete a fairly fine grade
manipulation tasks like unwrapping a
piece of candy like uh putting a cable
tie around a cable uh like zipping up a
hoodie and so forth
uh and the really cool thing about this
setup is that it um the total cost of
all four arms
um in this setup and other parts is less
than 20K this is less than the cost of a
single industrial arm
uh it's we're also planning to open
source both the hardware setup as well
as
um some some software that we've
developed for the system uh and it's
also a lot of fun to play with and I
think it will help us actually move
Beyond Simple pick and place tasks to
some of the tasks that you can see here
um tests that require dexterity that
require very quick motions
um
and and so forth and we also have some
initial results that have found that for
some of these tasks we could actually
train the robot to complete it
autonomously
cool
um I guess oh yeah and the other thing
they'll mention here is um these these
robots are quite low cost I actually
wasn't sure that the low-cost robots
would be capable of some of these things
and actually the manufacturer of these
robots uh trust and Robotics also didn't
know that their own robots were capable
of these kinds of tasks like putting uh
RAM into a a motherboard for example
um great uh with that I'd like to
acknowledge uh all the members of our
research lab and we have plenty of time
for for questions thanks everyone
great thank you so much Chelsea uh
extremely interesting presentation and I
saw a bunch of questions coming in
um they both tried to get to as many as
we can but if we have some additional
questions don't hesitate to still use
the Q a box uh and ask your questions
um Chelsea I saw a number of people very
interested in kind of the data sets
you're using and what actually the data
set is like how does it look like yeah
definitely so in the first part of the
talk the data set corresponded to
teleoperated demonstrations and what
that means is that we control the robot
with a VR controller to try to match we
basically have it we program it to match
the end effector of the robot to um the
position of or basically take actions
kind of mimicking the position of the VR
controller and during that process we
record images from the robot's cameras
we record the kind of position of the
arm which is measured by the joining
goals of um the angles of all the joints
as well as you can compute the 3D
position and orientation of the gripper
and then we also record the action that
was commanded to move the robot and so
generally you can think of this as
videos plus
um some a sequence of low dimensional uh
sensor measurements on the robot arm
um I guess and then in the second part
of the talk um and some of the other
stuff it's all very similar so uh we
typically use RGB images as the kind of
observation space of the robot and some
of the work where I was showing
um that very simple kind of simulated
running task uh that was all low
dimensional it was just looking at the
positions of all of the joints and so
forth
um but in in everything else we're using
uh image observations it's also possible
to use depth um to use tactile sensors
and so forth uh there are various uh
kind of upsides and downsides of
different sensors
um but we've found RGB sensors to be our
RGB cameras like webcams to be a really
simple and uh scalable solution
there was actually a follow-up question
about the
the processing or like you know during
the training and experimentation and you
mentioned that all of these have
advantages disadvantages so like what is
the advantage and disadvantage of the
image processing and how can we improve
it
yeah so
um we're in all of this work we're
basically training neural networks end
to end so returning a single neural
network to take his input the image and
output actions
and so this means that there isn't any
kind of computer vision pipeline that is
trying to find objects in the image for
example we're actually just actually
kind of supervising the visual backbone
of the model for the task that the robot
is trying to complete and one advantage
of this is that it means that the like
the robot's perception is optimized for
the task
and um the reason why this is actually
quite nice is that if you imagine a kind
of a task of for example manipulating a
water bottle if you tried to develop a
vision pipeline for that you might try
to like exactly represent the 3D pose of
the bottle and exactly represent the
shape of the bottle
um and inevitably a vision system will
have some failures it won't be able to
precisely estimate all of that and you
don't actually need all of that
information in order to do very simple
tasks like picking up the bottle you
don't need to precisely know the 3D
positions and by optimizing the
perception pipeline for the task it can
basically learn heuristics and learn
shortcuts and only represent the
perceptual information that it needs uh
for the task
um you mentioned a little bit about kind
of sharing data and data being available
uh there was a follow-up question on
that about envisioning like reusing data
across projects and also institutions
um what's kind of your intake on data
like could you kind of uh dive a little
bit deeper on uh what you have said in
presentation
yeah definitely so I think that it's
really critical to start
um kind of actually having us share data
and pre-trained models ideally as well I
my dream is to actually uh basically at
least in the short term be able to
develop models like analogous to Bert or
analogous to GPT style models that
people can use off the shelf on a robot
um of course not for text generation but
actually for representing actions and
representing images and so forth in a
robotics Pipeline and getting value from
those kinds of models so
um I think it's really important for the
community to do that there's also
challenges
um One Challenge is that the like
different people use different control
stacks and different robots
um our initial efforts is we are
um at least with the kind of the
Community Driven effort that I mentioned
we're trying to at least start with a
single robot platform and setup but then
diversify in terms of environments
objects tasks and so forth uh and that
can at least give us a little bit of a
certainty in terms of trying to
um in a little bit it's a little bit
less risky and that we can kind of focus
on a platform that a lot of people in
the community use and then in the long
term I think it's really important to
also start to develop pre-trained models
that uh are a little bit more agnostic
to the particular Hardware so that maybe
you can't kind of zero shot handle a new
robot but you might be able to
um kind of spin up a new robot platform
more quickly than if you were to do
everything from scratch uh yeah so I
think that those those are some of the
considerations
perfect thank you so much uh when you
showed a last video like with the you
know the egg and like rapping like you
know the the kind of the the candy and
all these kind of thing there was a lot
of excitement actually in the audience
about that uh and the follow-up question
or one of the follow-up questions is
about like how far are we in like
getting this like further or like making
this actually the standard uh standard
thing happening in the world like making
it even applicable and like using it in
practice
yeah so we're really excited about that
project too uh and uh it's something
that we're actively working on we're
actually going to be uh releasing a
paper around that work probably one week
from today uh certainly definitely
within the next two weeks uh and our
initial kind of progress on that is
actually we've been able to train neural
networks to do some kinds of tasks like
that specifically a task like slotting a
battery into a remote control like being
able to kind of tear off a piece of tape
and put it on a box uh and things like
that put a shoe on a person
um but there's also lots of challenges
so
um
the I guess well at first we are like I
mentioned we're open sourcing the
hardware setup and so we're hoping that
other people will be as excited about
the platform as we are and actually
um kind of develop it and or kind of buy
it themselves and uh and collect data on
it and so forth
um
there are other challenges associated
with getting like policies to do those
kinds of tasks as well one challenge
that we've run into is that
um we've been able to do some tasks like
kind of tearing off a piece of tape and
so forth but for other tasks you need to
be able to react really quickly to
what's happening
um so for example the candy unwrapping
um you need to we actually were able to
get a policy to do the initial step of
like picking up the P um the two sides
of it and then pulling but then the next
step involves like finding where the
flap is on the candy and then kind of
opening um opening the candy and with a
small amount of data around 50
demonstrations we found that the robot
wasn't able to complete that next step
of kind of finding the flap and then
opening uh we think that with more data
we should be able to handle that sort of
um that sort of challenge
um but there's also a question of how
much data you might need and so uh we're
also trying to kind of do some research
along the lines of pushing kind of the
robot's ability to react to these
certain scenarios efficiently
um and so forth so
um yeah also happy to answer more
questions on on the topic of that
project
uh what are some of the most promising
approaches like you you find very
promising for building actually robots
with like true artificial intelligence
like
um would you be able to answer that
um I think that the uh
I think that I mean the approaches that
I talked about today I think are some of
the most promising because those are the
things that I'm working on and I
um I wouldn't work on them if I didn't
think that they were the most promising
so scaling up data I think is really
important allowing robots to and just
generally systems for adapting is really
important uh I think that embodiment I
like studying robots because they're
actually embodied in the real world in
the world that we live in and unlike uh
things like language models they have to
contend with
a lot of things that come up in the real
world that are that are really
challenging
[Music]
um
the another thing that I'll mention uh
is that I've been talking a lot about
scaling data and I think that we also a
lot of the data that I talked about
before was collected by a person
controlling the robot and I think that
in the long term we really need robots
that can collect data autonomously on
their own uh and kind of operate with
autonomy in the real world and that sort
of autonomy is surprisingly hard uh we
find that agents and robots will get
stuck all the time uh and and kind of
not be not sure what to do it's possible
that we need kind of a parent to help
the robot uh just like analogous to how
kids have have parents um that are
helpful
[Music]
um
but yeah there's yeah lots of lots of
open problems and yeah generally the
things I'm I find most promising are
along the lines of what I presented
today
and um if I follow up on that maybe it's
the same answer like which months are
you the most excited about or like you
know what you actually hope to see maybe
in the next let's say 10 15 years uh
something you're very excited about
hoping to see
yeah
um
so I think that everything that like all
the ideas that I presented are I think
are necessary like I think that we need
broad data sets we need to adapt at test
time
um to get robots that can operate in the
real world uh the
[Music]
um
so I think that there isn't like any one
thing necessarily that that I'm most
excited about because I think that I
guess I think that robotics is a really
hard problem uh and I'm a little bit
more somewhat pessimistic I think in
terms of like actually the kind of
timeline for getting robots out into the
real world
um that said in the next kind of five to
ten years I'd love to see kind of
results that show that we can start to
push robots out of the lab into uh
unstructured environments and uh and so
forth uh with these kinds of learning
based approaches uh and also start to
see kind of pre-trained models start to
pop up that are useful and can be used
off the shelf by um by lots of people
thank you so much and I apologize I
apologies to put you on the spot
um we also had some people uh who are a
little bit newer to the field of
Robotics like what would you advise them
like where to get started where to learn
more
yeah definitely
um I think that my biggest piece of
advice is try to is just like starting
by
um getting your feet wet I think that uh
the my first experience working
well so I did a little bit of like Lego
robotics uh in
um in middle school I guess and that was
fun and I definitely kind of introduced
all the challenges that come up with
building a system with different
components with sensors with actuators
um and that was fairly accessible and
then I also
um in in college took a course on
Robotics and uh it was a lab course
where we kind of built a robot from
scratch uh built some sensors for it and
actually also
um
uh yeah also
had the robot um do various tasks and so
forth
um in our research we mostly buy robots
off the shelf and really focus on the
brand of the robot which I think is
really the bottleneck I don't think
we're that limited by the hardware and
fortunately there are some robot
platforms that are uh fairly well
they're getting more and more
inexpensive so
um there are various like mobile robot
platforms that have a few Wheels um like
I think Amazon has a platform that
um called The Deep racer that's a few
hundred dollars um and there's some
other other platforms as well and yeah I
think that trying to uh if that's
something that's kind of Within Reach
then uh then I think that yeah trying to
trying to actually just try stuff out on
the robot is a great place to get
started
um of course another place to get
started is to to learn more about
reinforcement learning um as Petra
mentioned I'm teaching a course on deep
reinforcement learning in um
in the spring and there's also lots of
resources online to uh yeah to explore
these kinds of things
maybe the last question because I see
that you know the questions still keep
coming but at the same time like we need
to actually make the stop at some point
um like what would you recommend uh as
those resources Chelsea like you know
where to look for where to find out
what's happening in robotics in the
field like how to learn more like any
favorite blogs you read like any
favorite kind of websites you follow
what would you recommend
yeah so
um let's see so
in terms of like tools
um like one physics simulator that we
use a lot is the majoco physics
simulator and it's fully open source and
if you want to get started playing
around with robots in simulation
um that that could be a kind of a good
place to start I think there's some
starter examples and you can try to get
the robot and simulation to do different
things
um the in terms of
um resources for
um for just kind of learning about high
level ideas of the field uh Peter abiel
who actually was uh my one of my PhD
advisors he has a podcast called the
robot brains podcast uh and that's a
great place to learn about various
experts in the field uh including both
academics as well as people in industry
um
and then I mean if you really want to
dive deep you can look at uh kind of
robot conferences like robotic science
and systems is a conference that I uh we
submit to a lot and then also uh the
conference on robot learning uh are both
great and oftentimes they have actually
videos of the talks uh at these
conferences in addition to the paper
proceedings available online
um and then uh yeah I mean there's
various course content that I think is
great and course content is probably
actually
um in some ways like more educational uh
and and more useful than uh than like
conference videos for example because
they're really aimed at teaching rather
than being aimed at uh kind of sharing
latest research results so it kind of
depends on on what you're looking for
okay perfect thank you so much Chelsea
uh we will wrap it here uh thank you so
much all for all the questions we will
try to kind of stay on and follow up on
the ones that are open if you can answer
them uh but do appreciate your time
Chelsea thank you so much for making the
time to do this and we will be making
this recording available to you so if
you missed some part we would like to
re-watch you can do that so thank you
everybody have a nice day and stay safe